make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and uh i have been trying to find a
way recently to
get us caught up on the x-men stuff and
to do it in the reading order the
biggest problem here is there's just
too much it's too much to try to do in
order of
of like how you would actually read it
so the only way to do this is to
basically do it as entire volumes right
entire runs so what we're gonna do here
is we're going to
basically finish out the the instances
of dawn of x stuff right the things that
we didn't finish marauders new mutants
excalibur different things like that and
we're just going to do it as the
individual volume so
it won't necessarily be in like issue by
issue reading order like the way that we
did jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers because i was wanting to do it
that way it's simply just too much
so with this instance we're basically
picking up kind of continuing on i guess
really uh where we started with the
marauders in the sense that
if you guys recall and we did this quite
some time ago it was actually last year
when we started it they basically had
what was
essentially the return of the hellfire
club but it's really considered the
hellfire trading company now all this
came out of like the formation of
krakowa and a unified mutant
empire or mutant nation uh that existed
there and so previously the hellfire
club was just a single group of mutants
who existed out there
like so many other different groups of
mutants but the difference is that the
hellfire club
would actually work to gain power and
money through like
subterfuge right so they would work
largely behind the scenes but they would
influence governments companies
different things like that
and it was all just to kind of bolster
their own power across the entirety of
the world when krakow was launched then
basically
the the hellfire club as it existed was
essentially disbanded and all the
various members ended up taking up arms
with krakowa and then it was relaunched
as a hellfire trading
company now one of the things that i got
on is you had a woman by the name of
zhao
who had basically put out there that her
husband had been taken by mutants right
or that he had essentially been whisked
away and the result of this
is that it led to it really kind of
allowed zou to kind of go forward as
just another member out there who was
largely
anti-mutant now in hindsight you know at
the time that i was reading this it
really seemed like it was kind of
building up a lot of anti-mutant groups
the reality is that it was really just
kind of a human response to the idea
that mutants were consolidating in a
singular location it was pretty
straightforward and pretty basic if
we're being a little honest with
ourselves but one of the missions that
kitty pride is on alongside bishop who
for those of you guys who don't know
bishop has the ability to absorb the
energies of others and then channel it
back at him or really their power
with the exception of telepathy but he
can absorb all kinds of energy and then
just channel it back at people
in different ways concussive blast is
usually how it goes they're on a mission
to essentially find out the truth about
what jail's talking about only to find
out that her husband
is actually being held captive by zhao
and the reason why is because if you
guys recall
one of the things that had happened in
the rise of the mutant population
and the the launcher of the creation of
kokoa is you had a cult that gave way
called the order of x
and this was basically humans that
worshiped mutants right they were
literally part of a pro-mutant cult and
her husband had joined one right zao's
husband basically joined one and because
her entire all of her aspirations were
predicated on the idea that no one could
know
that she was pro-mutant because or
really her husband was pro-mutant
because she was so staunchly anti-mutant
she'd effectively locked him away
and so when kitty pride and bishop
rescue her husband and then basically
bring him
in front of her while she's in taipei
arena essentially
in front of the world that this
basically leads to the revelation that
she lied about
everything which completely discredits
her on the political scene and so in
response to this what she ends up doing
is basically meeting with the newly
launched hellfire club
which is actually being uh being ran by
kade kilgore now here's the thing those
of you guys who don't know who kade
kilgore is and if you don't i
i but god won't be tied you cade kilgore
is
amazing he has no powers right this kid
has no powers or no abilities
but he is ruthless for a little kid
check this out
kate kilgore killed his dad and took
over his company like literally
orchestrated his dad being ousted from
his own company
took it over himself and then had his
dad killed like how's that for ruthless
right that's pretty intense but the the
thing that you kind of follow up with
after that
it's kind of this uh this this thing
that's going on between christian frost
and bobby drake now of course
it makes perfect sense but christian
frost is basically the brother of emma
frost right he's the only male
in the frost family and one of the cool
little tidbits about his character is
that one he's in a relationship with
bobby drake
and then two he's immune to emma frost's
telepathy and it works like that with
everybody in the frost family they're
all immune to the powers of the other
members of their family but one of the
things that's happening
is christian is trying to get bobby
drake over to his side
you know to basically join his
organization and bobby drake's like no
right i'm part of the marauders with
kitty pride
it's all good but one of the things that
goes on here this is kind of important
is what's happening with sebastian shaw
right so one of the things that we
talked about in the last uh the last
time that we did these videos
is that sebastian shaw was really
believe he really believed he was in
line
for the position as the red king of the
hellfire club instead they made kitty
pride the red queen
and the result of this is that it
basically put him in a position to where
the power he was most uh most commonly
accustomed to
was essentially stripped of him right
because he was one of the de facto
leaders of the original hellfire club
and
and the expectation of shaw was that
with the hellfire club being rebranded
as a hellfire trading company it would
just be a lateral move and he would just
move over into this new organization
and all the power that he previously
enjoyed would stay the same
but it's a reshuffling across the board
right in its entirety and kitty pride
doesn't really pull any punches right
she's like hey like you know i gotta
admit
it's really good having a spot that was
originally meant for you sebastian shaw
mostly because of the fact that you
caused the x-men so much hell over the
years why she doesn't extend that kind
of disdain towards emma frost
is largely because of generation x right
that's basically what it is so you guys
who don't know
kitty pride was never officially part of
generation x honestly she was a little
too old for it by the time it came
around
but jubilee certainly was if you guys
ever watched x-men the animated series
she actually
was releasing comics before x-men the
animated series came out
so the thing to know is that when emma
frost first popped up on the scene
uh she was basically a villain of the
x-men later on she formed what was what
i consider to be
the antithesis of the new mutants at the
time which was basically like her
own her own group called the hellions
largely you know once the hellions were
totally obliterated she ended up just
kind of turn coding and basically became
a good guy
joined the x-men and then had her own
team called generation x but the fact
that emma frost was at one point a
villain of the x-men and then went on to
become
a ally to the team and even a leader
really earned the respect of kitty pride
along with pretty much everybody there
they were really hesitant at first they
were like look i mean you've been trying
to kill us for years
why should we believe you now and she
was kind of like well because i'm i'm
trying to be a good guy
you have to believe me that was
basically it
and so it was ultimately she ended up
becoming uh becoming a member of the the
x-men franchise or the x-men
uh landscape you know ever ever since
then sebastian shaw
never did that he was always a dick and
he was always trying to kill the x-men
so no wonder nobody trusts this guy i
mean plus he's got mutton chops what
have you ever heard of anybody extending
trust a person who had mutton chops
right i know with the exception of buddy
of mine daniel i wouldn't trust
anybody who had mutton chops right
that's just that kind of person looks
us so the whole thing behind this is you
have this really interesting
conversation that takes place between
emma frost and kitty pride one of the
things to remember
is that kitty pride at this point could
not pass through the cocon gates
and because of that uh sebastian shaw
and he's not the only one
does not actually see her as a rightful
member of krakowa the island more or
less rejected her we never really found
out or at least at the time we didn't
really know why
we simply just knew that it didn't and
so as a result of that there were a lot
of people who were staunchly pro-mutant
and really more
about about mutant khan being a purest
race that didn't really see her as
somebody who belonged there
now the reality is she's been such a
long-standing member of the x-men
and actually at one point had the
opportunity to side with emma frost and
didn't instead she sided with the x-men
so she never became part of the hellions
but uh but because she's been a part of
the team for so long no one's really
questioning you know what's going on
it's really kind of the thing of like
why can't she get in like that was kind
of the big mystery that was going on
at the time and so it's a little a
little bit of a cool thing because her
concern
is that if she can't access the island
of kokoa there's no reason to believe
the resurrection protocols would work
for her and so if she dies
she stays dead there's no real way to
bring her back that's her biggest
concern and that she's going to end up
dying just
old and alone on this island by herself
and no one there to really keep her i
mean she'll have friends who were there
but like that'll be it she'll have to
watch them stay youthful while she grows
old
and so it's a it's kind of a cool little
bit of a little bit of a bonding moment
there but in the midst of this whole
thing where they basically rescued a
whole bunch of of mutants that were
being held captive uh they end up
getting a kind of emergency call
that like hey like there is another
situation again uh we gotta go out there
and we gotta rescue some more mutants
right because that's kind of the charter
behind the marauders story as they ride
around on this amazing yacht that they
literally
jacked right they just they like
hijacked this like billion dollar yacht
and like they just ride around blasting
like 80s rock music
which is awesome and like rescuing
people on missions which is
even more awesome like i love the idea
of the marauders it was like the coolest
thing ever
but but essentially they arrive you know
the marauders arrive and
really kind of save you know all these
younger mutants that are that are
basically being held captive there's a
couple things going on here one
the hellfire club led by kade kilgore is
essentially making their move
in the sense that they're launching a
striker or trying to find and really
test the power
of the marauders to see what all that
they can do the marauders of course end
up coming out on top
they grab all these kids and they
basically save the day and then
essentially leave but the other thing
that goes on
is this vessel seemingly comes out of
nowhere and then it has this group on it
that's called hominis virendi
now i will say that hamas virendi is an
organization that's kind of been
met with mixed reactions and i'm not
going to lie you know it's
it's interesting for example i saw a
review recently that really seemed to
kind of nail it in the sense that
while the the whole run of jonathan
hickman and really the whole relaunch of
x-men under hickman
is really kind of dealing with like the
adaptability and the capability of the
mutant population
this grander story arc of like kicking
the future right inheriting the future
from humanity
to solidify their continued existence
and the war that's to come between
humans and mutants this
grand scale war that we saw in house and
powers of x uh
that it really seems to be kind of
almost marginalized by the idea that
like
kitty pride of the marauders are
basically fighting a bunch of
billionaire kids who
are essentially geniuses trying to like
wreak havoc on the mutant population
that that
there are other people who kind of look
at it and say no like it's actually
really cool right it breeds a sort of
unsuspecting
uh gambit to the x-men landscape in the
sense that we've seen
so many instances where there's like
super-powered beings who have abilities
or government-backed organizations that
are looking to take down mutants or
whatever
that is cool to see like a reinvented
version of the hellfire club that's
basically ran by younger people uh it
really kind of depends on on how you
slice it but the reality of this is that
ominous verendi is basically
ran or it's it was kind of created and
launched by the new hellfire club of
cade kilgore and all those guys and so
literally
they're looking to do what so many other
people are doing and trying to take down
the mutant population but they're doing
it on a far more grand scale we'll talk
about how grand that scale is here in a
minute and we'll talk about it more in
future videos
but the overall gist here is that kitty
pride and their efforts to take out
these guys are basically met by the
arrival
of chenzao and then donald pierce now
chinzao of course again we've talked
about her donald pierce the reason why
kitty pride's so pissed off to see him
is donald pierce has been a
long time enemy of the x-men right there
was even one point where he only joined
the inner circle of the hellfire club
just so he could try to destroy it
because he hated mutants that much
the guy is is he's interesting depending
on who's writing the story he's one of
those characters he's he's not
consistently interesting right it's not
one of these things where it's like
every single story that donald pierce is
in is amazing it's
there's really like if i had to give it
a ratio i'd be like 90
crap 10 cool that's kind of how how
donald pierce works
that not all of his stories are
interesting and even like you guys will
kind of see in this one he's not really
all that intriguing that you end up
having homonymous verende that are doing
everything they can
to try to take out the mutants but storm
kind of jumps in and then literally
kicks donald pierce off the boat and
that's more or less donald pierce right
i mean that's that's really all that
happens to him he's kind of a throwaway
character honestly he's been that way
ever since chris claremont introduced
the revelation that he only joined the
hellfire club for the purpose of trying
to destroy the mutant population
as soon as donald pierce was ousted in
that way and then basically booted from
the hellfire club he's kind of been one
of the many whipping boys that marvel
has
uh that they just they just beat on
right they just they they write these
stories and he just gets trashed and
nothing he does matters and that's
basically it
that's ultimately with the day being
saved and this disney of the hominis
verendi more or less being defeated it
leads to everybody kind of heading out
right everybody basically you know the
the mutants heading back to kokoa to
drop these kids off and for them to kind
of take up safe haven
on the island itself among the mutant
population and then out of nowhere
sebastian shaw pops up and we basically
end up finding out that sebastian shaw
had more or less orchestrated
all of this that he had approached
donald pierce and basically offered him
a bunch of money to work alongside
chenzao that shenzhou herself is working
alongside the health the the newly
created hellfire club that there doesn't
really seem to be
any direct indication that sebastian
shaw is working directly with
cade kilgore and his hellfire club it
kind of seems like one of these things
where he's working through
proxies but the long and short of it is
that he's working to basically
take out kitty pride by getting people
like bobby drake to leave the team and
then side with people like christian
frost
different things like that but one of
the things that he does here is he
actually grabs some cocon seeds
that basically have fast growing vines
most likely grown by black tom cassidy
who's able to control vines or control
really any kind of plant life but the
important thing here is that he
basically ends up having these vines
that essentially neutralize the power of
kitty pry
and they literally drag her down into
the ocean and then it kills her right
kitty pry dies and it's kind of a crazy
thing because at the time that happened
it was like wow because as far as i'm
aware kitty pry is one of those
characters that marvel's never killed
before
and it's kind of nuts to see that whole
thing happen but kitty pride was
basically killed off
and the idea here is that because
sebastian shaw had previously been
rejected
as the as the the red king that most
likely he it would just kind of be
viewed as like a mission gone wrong
or something like that and ultimately it
would just kind of be chalked up to
either his son
shinobi taking over that role or that
role being offered to him but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]